Working at the SCP Foundation can really get
your appetite going.
After spending a rough shift monitoring the
acid levels in SCP-682’s tank, or performing
the rituals necessary to keep the Devourer
of Worlds on the other side of SCP-2317, sometimes
you just need a quick snack to hold you over
before you return to the old grind.
Problem is, at the SCP Foundation, even the
break room can be perilous.
Dr. Dan is notorious for pilfering pudding
cups from the communal fridge, and ever since
The Administrator himself stole your tuna
sandwich, you just don’t feel safe spending
your lunch break on-site anymore.
But this presents its own series of issues:
You only have an hour for lunch, and obviously
you can’t order in due to security issues.
Also, if you’re eating off-site, you have
even less time to finish your lunch, because
the site you’re currently stationed at is
relatively remote.
We’re talking at least a half-hour round-trip
to actually get to somewhere, so you’re
gonna need your food fast.
And when it comes to fast food, few eateries
are as prolific as the Golden Arches: McDonalds.
And just to clarify, this video is not sponsored.
We’re going to tell you about a horrifying
anomalous secret that this company really
doesn’t want you to know about.
Let’s not think about that just yet, though.
Your stomach is rumbling, and you need that
quarter pounder so bad that even being trapped
in the Red Reality with Dr. Scranton couldn’t
stop you from getting it.
When you finally arrive, you buy your typical
order: A quarter pounder with french fries,
a coffee, and a McFlurry.
You see Dr. Clef a few tables down eating
a box of chicken nuggets and ketchup, but
decide not to engage.
As you sit and enjoy your meager little lunch,
knowing you’ll probably be coordinating
the cleaning efforts of SCP-173’s containment
chamber by the end of the day, your eyes drift
over to something even more unsettling: Happy,
the current mascot for McDonalds Happy Meals.
You can’t help but shudder.
You’ve seen some pretty horrifying things
on the job.
Nightmarish things.
You fear no monster, but that thing?
It scares you.
Those big, soulless eyes.
The wide, gaping maw full of too-white teeth.
Its diabolical sneakers.
No child should ever have to look at that.
You can’t help but wonder, whatever happened
to Ronald McDonald, the hamburger happy clown
that’d shilled fast food to you throughout
your childhood?
What was he up to now?
Well, we have the answer for you, but I’ll
warn you: You may not be quite as eager to
suck down a Big Mac and diet coke after hearing
this.
Ronald McDonald, first introduced as the company
mascot in 1963, had a pretty good run before
finally being largely phased out by the company
in the mid-2010s for a greater focus on the
nasty little box homunculus.
You can thank John Wayne Gacy, Pennywise,
and those goofballs dressing up as clowns
back in 2016 for that.
But like anyone who loses favor stateside,
Ronald had a prosperous career ahead of him
outside of the country.
Well, not the Ronald we know, at least.
You see, in an undisclosed cattle farm in
2004, most likely in North America, a monster
was born.
A horrific abomination, birthed from a cow,
like many have theorized about SCP-058, the
Heart of Darkness.
But this nasty little creature wasn’t a
giant heart with a stinger and scorpion legs.
In many ways, it appeared superficially humanoid,
save for its stark white skin, its thick red
lips, and its full head of bright, frizzy
red hair.
But that was only the start of the unnerving
strangeness exhibited by this miracle child.
It was born with white gloves and long, clownish
shoes seemingly grafted to its feet.
Fresh from birth, the creature was huge, with
a disproportionately large head and wide,
disgusting pores that seemed to perpetually
leak fry oil.
The creature was unresponsive to any kind
of external stimuli, perhaps suggesting it
was braindead, and it remained completely
dormant most of the time.
While most people would have screamed, run
away, or called the police, the farmers at
this particular cattle farm decided to let
it ride, and see how this whole nightmarish
affair played out.
That sense of curiosity and patience would
soon pay off for them financially.
It didn’t take long for the creature to
grow.
The bigger it got, the more it looked like
a giant, mutant version of McDonalds’ iconic
mascot, Ronald McDonald.
And this wasn’t just a coincidence, either.
It turned out that this monster was somehow
intrinsically linked to the McDonalds brand,
because once a day, the creature would horrifically
unhinge its jaw, and begin to barf out a huge
quantity of McDonalds food.
And we’re not talking about raw materials
that are then converted into McDonalds food.
The creature, later dubbed SCP-5962, vomited
out fully-packaged McDonalds products.
The owners of this clownish monster had just
hit the lottery - so to speak.
While the particulars of the deal are unclear,
they somehow contacted a representative of
the McDonalds corporation based in China.
In exchange for presumably a large sum of
money, Chinese McDonalds operatives covertly
entered the country and shepherded the now-massive
creature over to a McDonalds-owned warehouse
in Beijing.
By this point, it was around four meters tall
and weighed over five tons.
It was kept inside a cage and housed at some
cost, but soon enough, the creature was paying
for itself.
As we mentioned before, the creature constantly
secreted fry oil, which was siphoned off for
use in preparing McDonalds food across the
country.
The huge quantity of packaged food that it
vomited out every day was also shipped off
to restaurants across the country, making
the Chinese branch of McDonalds incredibly
financially successful.
They were able to make an almost complete
profit on all of these foods and drinks, once
transport costs were subtracted, of course.
SCP-5962 had become McDonalds China’s best-kept
secret, but of course, no secret this sensational
could stay under wraps forever.
No matter how much people in the warehouse
were paid or threatened for their silence,
if your day job was siphoning grease off of
a giant mutant clown for the purpose of preparing
McDonalds food across the country, there’d
be no way that you wouldn’t speak to somebody
about it.
Nobody knows whose loose lips sunk this incredibly
profitable ship, but rumors began to spread
around Beijing about a huge clown inside of
a McDonalds packaging facility.
That was when local field agents of the SCP
Foundation finally took notice.
Two agents, Johnathan Zhang and George Nagasu,
were dispatched to perform an infiltration
mission along with a team of backup personnel.
They entered the warehouse, apprehending any
employees they found.
As they and their reinforcements reached the
Northern side of the facility, they found
SCP-5962 with a heavy collar around its neck,
chained to the ground like King Kong, as McDonalds
employees wheeled away carts of packaged food.
Neither of the attending agents were fans
of McDonalds food, but even then, just seeing
this horrible display was enough to make them
feel nauseous.
The creature was taken and contained by the
SCP Foundation, who conducted a number of
tests on it.
They found that the monster had no real internal
organs save for 27 interconnected stomachs.
Genetically, they also found that the creature
was far more cow than human.
The same could sadly not be said for the food
that SCP-5962 was vomiting out.
Seriously, if you were already feeling a little
queasy from all this, we need to warn you
that this is the part where things get really
vile.
Let’s talk about what the McDonalds food
barfed up by SCP-5962 was actually made out
of.
As we alluded to earlier, the food exuded
by the creature was genetically human, with
DNA often matching that of people who are
alive and in no way affected by this anomalous
process.
Tests have indicated that certain foods, condiments,
and beverages correspond to more specific
types of bodily tissue and liquid.
For example, the bacon and fries were shown
to be cartilage and ligaments.
The bread turned out to be made from hair,
nails, and skin.
The coffee was liquified fecal matter.
The chicken nuggets were made from fingers,
ovaries, and testes.
Even the water was a mix of saline and sweat,
and of course, the ice cream was comprised
of pus, bone marrow, feces, and nasal mucus,
depending on the flavor.
You get the idea.
We’ll stop listing off examples before you
lose your lunch, but rest assured, all the
food produced by SCP-5962 was made of human
organic matter.
When the SCP Foundation interviewed Mr. Chen,
the manager of the facility where SCP-5962
was being held, before his amnestic treatment,
he seemed incredibly casual about the whole
thing.
As far as he was concerned, the food still
tasted exactly the same as regular McDonalds
food, and it didn’t appear to have any adverse
health effects beyond what you could expect
from regular, non-anomalous fast food.
It’s actually less cruel and disturbing
than the slaughterhouses where this meat is
typically obtained.
Mr. Chen also contested that SCP-5962 wasn’t
at all dangerous, either: The only time it
ever performed a defensive action was when
an employee of the enemy fast-food franchise,
Burger King, entered its vicinity.
The creature vomited a stream of hot coffee
at the corporate interloper like a firehouse
until he left, suggesting that it does have
some kind of strange inherent loyalty to the
McDonalds company.
But still, other than this isolated incident,
the creature had never even displayed sentience.
It was a big, strange, clownish McDonalds
food dispenser.
When questioned about the origins of SCP-5962,
Mr. Chen once again underplayed the strangeness
of the situation, saying that he’d heard
rumors the farm that sold him SCP-5962 had
also sold other strange, anomalous creatures
to eager buyers in the US.
The farm - which we can only assume is situated
right next to a radioactive waste dump - was
also behind SCP-4158, also known as Big Charlie.
This giant, omnivorous, and seemingly immortal
mutant cow is believed to have been birthed
from a non-anomalous cow sold to the Butchers
Block Slaughterhouse.
It looked hideous and seemed to suffer from
a wide variety of health issues, leading to
the employees at the slaughterhouse trying
to put the creature out of its misery.
However, no matter how hard they tried to
kill the monster, it just wouldn’t die.
Its bones were pretty much indestructible,
and no matter how much of its flesh was cut
off, it just kept growing back, causing no
ill effects to the creature itself.
Eventually, the slaughterhouse workers tried
cooking and eating the meat, leading to them
discovering it tasted just as good as non-anomalous
meat.
Much like the Chinese McDonalds and SCP-5962,
the workers had just hit the lottery with
Big Charlie.
As long as they kept feeding the monster,
which ate everything from bricks to other,
non-anomalous cows, it provided a pretty much
limitless supply of meat, giving them unprecedented
economic prosperity.
In other words, Big Charlie was a literal
cash cow.
Jeff Fine, the slaughterhouse director, even
started worshipping Big Charlie as a kind
of demi-god by drinking his blood.
He believed that Big Charlie was a savior,
sent to lift them all out of their struggle
and desperation.
Sadly for them, the SCP Foundation sent them
right back when Big Charlie escaped their
slaughterhouse, and Foundation field agents
found, secured, and contained it.
It was a sad day for the Butchers Block.
So, what have we learned today?
Whether you’re in the US of A or the Chinese
heartland, if you’re chowing down on fast
food, you really have no idea where it came
from.
I mean, we kind of knew that already, but
for all we know, the food you’re enjoying
could have been vomited up by a giant fat
clown, or cut from the flesh of a mutated
cow.
Just think about that next time you’re enjoying
a burger.
But hey, let’s be honest with ourselves,
we’ll all probably still eat it.
Now go check out “SCP-3166 - Monster Garfield
Attack (Gorefield)” and “Killer Living
Graffiti SCP-1155 - Predatory Street Art”
for more strange threats from the SCP Foundation!